at the founder of infinity AI I hope to
make my startup a top services provider
in the global artificial intelligence
Spectrum I believe that the skills
that I have acquired from the course in
AI for decision making from water will
help me take steps to expand my business
hey I'm Tushar sisad I live in Pune and
I have my whole startup Infinity AI
before starting my own business I gained
some experience in the management domain
I've worked with giving Automotive
players like Mahindra and Tata as a
senior manager after getting more than
16 years of experience I started my own
set of businesses I already knew how to
make business decisions but I was not
sure about the benefits that AI can
provide in a business when I launched my
AI startup taking a certification course
made sense after much thought and
research I opted for the AI for decision
making business strategies and
applications course offered by simply I
definitely gain knowledge about various
AI tools and Services I also enjoyed the
course it was an awesome experience with
respect to the content and syllabus very
easy to understand the flow from the
experts
the instructions actually help you
improve your grasp on the content it
stays with you the real life examples
they provide helps you understand better
I learned about Big Data machine
learning and much more at infinite AI
we'll be providing air-based solutions
to sectors ranging from Healthcare
banking Automotive education
Etc
we'll be helping companies enhance their
employee touch points and customer
experience basically wherever AI can be
used now that I understand the
technology it I am better position we'll
soon be launching AI based products with
the skills from the goals will come
handy I feel that I am more considered
as an entrepreneur now
upscaling with simply learn align with
my passion for learning
I like to travel and meet new people
I like to explore various Avenues which
is quite risky
upskilling can help you reduce the risk